hey kenntemich noch ich will eure mal
ware ja ich weiss ich war jetzt ein
bisschen länger weg vom fenster
beziehungsweise habe auch in der letzten
zeit nicht so viele videos gemacht das
hat den einfachen grund dass ich immer
besuch hatte wirklich immer der eine
besucher ist gegangen und am nächsten
tag ist er andere besuch gekommen
seit ich umgezogen bin habe ich nämlich
ein gästebett und die leute sie lieben
das es ist ja auch schön besucht zu
haben aber es hält ein wirklich vom
drehen ab oder von den trip streams oder
von den maßen er videos oder von sonst
nix und ich war noch über ostern in köln
denn der 24 stunden church street von
rewe lief dort und ich war ein gast und
habe ihn unterstützt und es wurden
79.000 euro gesammelt
charity gut money money money ist gut
und ich bin krank geworden aber das hat
mich nicht ab davon dieses video zu
drehen denn das wollte ich schon
unbedingt die ganze zeit drehen und
heute ist der tag der tage gekommen ich
dachte nämlich dass es ganz schlau wäre
nach dem kamel video mit meinem bruder
vielleicht das thema nochmal aufzupassen
ich wollte es noch einmal so ein
bisschen abrunden die ganze geschichte
eine schöne schleife drum machen ohne es
wegpacken also nicht mein bruder aber
das ist und dann jumpen wir auch gleich
right into der erste punkt den ich
ansprechen möchte und zwar zu dem titel
das video ist nämlich mein behinderter
bruder und ich testen eine beruhigende
kamel fahren einige leute dachten dass
ich einfach meinen bruder beleidigen
wollte bis sie das video angeklickt
haben und gemerkt haben der ist ja
wirklich behindert andere leute hat das
gar nicht gestört und ganz andere leute
haben gesagt dass ich klicke damit mache
ich werde jetzt nicht wikipedia zitieren
aber krebs bedeutet ungefähr bei den
titel wählen der nicht so ganz der
realität entspricht etwas dramatischer
darstellt als es ist und da muss ich
sagen meinen titel hat eigentlich genau
das gesagt was im video passiert ist ein
behinderter bruder und ich besuchen eine
kamelfarm und das war das video
natürlich hätte ich schreiben können
mein bruder und ich aber da sind video
ja besonders darum gehen das thema
behinderung aufzugreifen wenn ich das
meinen behinderter bruder und ich eine
sehr guter titel werde auch für einen
film fällt mir jetzt gerade auch ein
bisschen so ich stelle mir das so ein
bisschen vor wie ziemlich beste freunde
ein behinderter bruder und ich gibt
schon so ein film ich hätte auf jeden
fall gute stories für seinen film um das
nochmal hier ganz deutlich darzustellen
nein ich habe kein klick gemacht und was
ganz eklig klingt um aus der behinderung
meines bruders profit herauszuschlagen
also klicks und mikes und manni
denn das war ja auch ein werbevideo und
das komplette geld dieses werbevideos
ging in die reha die mein bruder gerade
besucht hat in polen denn manchmal sind
krankenkassen super toll und manchmal
wie in diesem fall sind krankenkassen
wirklich jedes böse wort das mir jetzt
einfällt wie ein bisschen zu tun und
weil ihr alle meinen bruder so in den
himmel gelobt habt um geschrieben habe
wie toll er ist und nett und lustig und
süß möchte ich euch erzählen dass es bei
ihm angekommen ist und dass er sich sehr
sehr sehr über die kommentare gefreut
hat muss ich sagen dass ich glaube es
waren so 1500 kommentare und so 1499
gegen darum was für ein cooler typ ist
und ich glaube das hört man dann auch
mal gerne was mich unter den kommentaren
sehr bewegt hat waren eure geschichten
schicksalsschläge erfahrungen auch mit
behinderten mit kranken
familienmitgliedern man vergisst ganz
oft dass man nicht alleine
wenn so etwas passiert so habe ich das
noch aus meiner erfahrung denkt man
eigentlich nur warum passiert das dann
gerade mir warum uns also so wir stehen
hier alleine in dieser situation und es
gibt so viele familien die mit
schicksalsschlägen wie diesen leben
müssen und viele jugendliche und kinder
die auch wie ich durch so eine zeit
gehen müssen
in so einer zeit auch aufwachsen müssen
als es damals passiert ist war ich 14
jahre alt ich war mitten irgendwie ne
pubertät und am rausfinden wer bin ich
und man musste dann sehr schnell sehr
erwachsen werden also da ging es halt
dann nur noch um meinen bruder und es
war vollkommen in ordnung für mich ich
habe mich nicht benachteiligt gefühlt
aber ich glaube man braucht auf jeden
fall um einen guten und klaren kopf zu
kriegen einen ausgleich und leute die
sich dann nur um die geschwister kümmern
oder nun die eltern und nur um die
person die nicht wirklich betroffen ist
sondern nur hilft und genau zu diesem
thema hat sich ein projekt bei mir
gemeldet also nicht das projekt sondern
die menschen die in dem projekt arbeiten
dieses projekt finde ich so schön und so
wichtig dass ich euch unbedingt davon
erzählen wollte es heißt pausen taste
und ist vom nummer gegen kummer ev und
dem familienministerium und die
ministerium für zauberei und spaß der
beste satz der dieses projekt beschreibt
steht auch direkt auf der website wer
anderen hilft braucht manchmal selber
höfe pausen taste ist ein angebot für
kinder und jugendliche die sich um ihre
familie kümmern müssen und da geht es
nicht nur darum ob man ein
pflegebedürftiges familienmitglied hat
sondern vielleicht auch ein suchtkranker
oder ein psychisch krankes oder ein
sterbendes familienmitglied es ist so
wichtig dass wir aufeinander aufpassen
und dass wir menschen nicht auf der
strecke lassen die irgendwie viel
durchmachen müssen
ich will ich nur sagen dass wenn ihr
euch in einer situation befindet wo
familienmitglieder von euch wo ihr viel
arbeit reinstecken müssen oder die viel
pflege brauchen viel aufmerksamkeit
brauchen familienmitglieder die
vielleicht ja durch ihre suchtkrankheit
sehr belastend für euch sind oder durch
andere sachen schaut mal auf der website
vor bei www pausen testen.de dort gibt
es angebote in ein bundesländern in
manchen meeren manchen weniger aber auf
jeden fall gibt es überall angebote wo
ihr euch melden könnt es gibt die nummer
eine nummer bei der euch melden können
und wenn ihr euch überfordert fühlt wenn
ihr euch so fühlt dass es manchmal
einfach schwer zu schaffen ist dann
meldet euch dort schaut doch mal vorbei
und informiert euch und falls sie
jemanden kennt der in so einer situation
steckt dann erzählt ihm davon oder
schaut mal für die person
damit helfe dir auch gut weiter auf man
mit ihr seid nicht allein auf dieser
welt auch wenn es sich manchmal so
anfühlt okay ich glaube es hätte mir
damals sehr geholfen mit leuten darüber
zu sprechen oder coole aktion irgendwie
mit anderen zu machen die in meiner
situation sind weil man sich nicht zu
wichtig nehmen möchte das merke ich
tatsächlich noch bis heute dass es mir
schwer fällt meine bedürfnisse auch mal
an erster stelle zu stellen weil man
zeit so gewohnt ist wenn man es gewohnt
ist das also dass es jemanden in deinem
leben gibt der wichtiger ist nicht
wichtiger aber mehr aufmerksamkeit
braucht als man selbst
okay leute wenn ihr einfach in so einer
situation sagt bitte einfach auf 1000
taste ich möchte euch noch sagen dass
der link in der beschreibung ist ich
muss jetzt geht jetzt bin
es tut mir leid immer wenn ich wieder
anfange dann möchte ich heulen aber mir
geht's gut keine sorge ich mir geht es
wirklich kommt es ist sehr emotional
irgendwie darüber zu reden mann und
meine verabschiedung ist jetzt richtig
happy
ich möchte euch sagen dass irgendwo
kommt wieder bestimmt mehr
es kommen absolut ich bin jetzt wieder
im richtigen mindset ich habe jetzt
wieder zeit es stehen keine besucher an
mein urlaub ist für juni geplant das
heißt tänze mai und april ist noch frei
und ich drehe videos und ich freue mich
drauf und ich hoffe euch geht es gut und
wir sehen uns dann bis bald und folgt
ihr auf instagram und mein dick tag um
mein gott ich mach jetzt tik tok folgt
mit tik tok folgten ihr auf twitter
account
doch erst mal wieder gesund werden also
irgendwer hat heute den tiefen
geschnitten ich hab's gesehen bis dann
ja